Oh
day after day in the Sun and the wind
and the rain had climbed into the hills
this was where I was meant to be
[Music]
the more I learn the more I realized how
like us they were
stranger than fiction here we have a
perfect jane goodall paul blonde and
beautiful it would be the Cuban Z's in
the wilds of Africa were you ever really
very frightened I thought they were nice
at the most I had no idea of the
brutality the significance of the
studies there were some who tried to
discredit my observations because I was
a young untrained girl I didn't care
what anybody said
they would be sending out at the trunk
refer to document the chimpanzees we
both love being out in nature and we
both love the work we were doing we just
got on very well well it was like that
Geographic end of the funding for very
upsetting
unfortunately sad and it was like well
what do we do
[Applause]
how long are you going to be associated
with the chimpanzee
until I die
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]